[Musique]
pour
vu qu'on a eu le col red en dehors de
l'union européenne il n'y a pas de
certificat de rétablissement on est un
peu dans un flou
parce qu'on a un test positif mais qui
n'est pas de lieu qui n'a pas le qr
codes habituels et donc j'ai eu trois
semaines un mois pendant les fêtes où
j'ai dû du coup payer des tests de
dépistage de co vide
[Musique]
/
opel
[Musique]
dulko vide fin décembre donc au moment
où j'allais faire mon rappel en fait
donc mon pass surtout senti qu vite dès
maintenant nul n'existe plus au fait je
n'ai plus je n'ai plus rien donc en fait
si je viens en france je suis considéré
comme n'ayant pas de passes sanitaire ou
de passes vaccinale
[Musique]
il
on a eu des cas bien évidemment de
personnes qui se sont vraisemblablement
été qui ont été confrontés à ce cette
infection sans le savoir sans avoir été
testé et pour lesquelles on a vacciné
les ne s'est rien passé c'est pas la
situation idéale mais c'est pas non plus
quelque chose qui peut occasionner des
problèmes c'est médicaux majeurs